start on the right side Midway in the
back on the outside their dream on dream
on Dan Feldman NBC Sports what a Pascale
siakam do to give you guys so much
trouble tonight I think he played
amazing game obviously but you know he
got out in transition about our
transition D was horrible and I um I let
him get into rhythm in the first half
1st quarter really so I got to do a
better job of taking this rhythm away
and I will but you know he had a great
game but that's on me given that it was
his first Finals game but surprised you
that he was so aggressive oh no you know
different people have reacted
differently in different situations so I
don't but like I said I got to do a
better job of taking them out the game
left side row 2 to mark dreama mark
Schwartz ESPN you know the league so
well and see out comes a guy who sort of
came quickly from Africa hadn't played
the game very long what kind of
improvement did he show tonight from
other times that you've seen him in an
NBA game well I mean really the only
time I've ever really played it was last
year I played on the second time we
played them this year I probably played
16 minutes or something like that I was
just coming back from injury you know
you got to take your hat off to
regardless of this game you still have
to take your hat off to him even before
this game of what he's been able to
accomplish this year you know he's
become a guy and so you know you got a
he put a lot of work in and get there
and and I respect that but like I said I
gotta take him out of this series and
that's on me
sixth row on the right side rob a little
BSO defensively you guys were very
aggressive with Kawhi Leonard but they
did open up some other things for the
others on the Raptors what are some
things that you feel that you can you
guys can do better in Game two
defensively they kind of shut down the
others beyond Kawhi oh well I think we
got to do a better job early on like we
gave see I'll come a couple wide-open
threes we gave the saw wide open threes
and like there was no rotation so you
know you could guys those types
they get comfortable you know and it's a
different beast so I think we did a good
job on Kauai we got to keep that up but
we have to do a better job on everybody
else as well so now our rotations got to
be better you know we got to fly around
a little bit more and we got to stop
them from getting out in transition
left side front row Steve Ashburn
nba.com what effect if any did it have
that this series started on the road and
and the the atmosphere out there and I'm
wondering also what is it about your
team that if it's the playoffs sooner or
later you guys take care of your
business on the road I think it was
obviously a different field you know
we've already started to find us at home
but we you know we're relishing this
opportunity at the end of the day you
got to come on the road and win wine you
know that's still the mission we got to
win one game on the road and you know I
like where we are we didn't we didn't
play very well tonight at all and you
know we still had a chance the entire
game you know it was a great atmosphere
not that it you know this is a team a
city a country that hasn't seen the
finals ever here so you know respected
to be a great atmosphere and it was but
we can still play better and I know we
will left side on the outside - Tim Tim
Conley yeah it kind of picking up on
that Ramon do you obviously they were
impressive both ways but do you feel
like you guys might have not figured
some things out but work some things out
as this game went along did you feel
better at the end than you did at the
beginning yeah number one we got a lot
of conditioning back start that start
the game it was bit rough after 19 days
off but you know I think we just got a
better feel for like I said this is a
team that we really haven't played the
first time we played them Stef or I
myself didn't play second time we played
them Kawhi didn't play like so this is
essentially our first time playing this
team now that we got a feel for them we
got to tape to watch you know we know
what we can do better I like where we're
at especially like I said the way the
game went tonight we always had a chance
and we didn't play very well at all so
you know you leave this game feeling
as good as you possibly can feel knowing
that yeah we lost but we you know I
think we figured some things out in
there will be better next game left side
many way in the back mark the dream I'll
mark Medina berry newsgroup dream on
you've often mention in the past when
things aren't going your way as a team
that that Kevin can often you know be
the ultimate trump card what things were
difficult specifically without him
tonight I think number one we turned the
ball over 17 times they got 17 points
off those turnovers you know one of the
keys coming City game was to stop them
in transition you turn the ball over
that many times they were going to get
out of in transition so yeah you usually
do have Kevin there that though you know
throw the ball to but I don't
necessarily think the problem was our
offense outside of the turnovers you
know we just got to be better all around
the floor and especially on the
defensive end so sorry we'll be better
sorry dream on left side in the back hey
dream on just wanted you to talk a
little bit about that postgame scuffle
between you and Drake you got a question
about basketball it wasn't really a
scuffle because I didn't hit him and he
didn't hit me or I didn't push him and
he didn't push me we talked we boxed a
little bit but I wouldn't necessarily
consider that a scuffle not really what
I personally will consider a scuffle
thank you